[Music]
what does everybody happy Thursday
welcome back to the show this is take to
edit the first part out apparently there
was no audio you guys can see there's a
little something different about me
today while I'm back in the studio I'm
excited to be here normally I'm doing
this now from home but my internet went
out at home so here I'm risking life and
limb to bring you the show but I'm being
safe and being smart and wearing my
mascara there's only a few of us in the
office but we're gonna be doing logo
design review today and it's a little
different than our normal format first
we're going to feature one person we're
gonna talk about the logos you love to
hate yes that's right we're gonna take
on a famous logo that everybody hates on
design Twitter and we're gonna redesign
it we're gonna redesign it and today
joining us is the lovely hadeel
Syed Ahmad and she's from Amman Jordan
and if you guys want to check out her
work go to hadeel ahmad calm it's right
there at the bottom we'll include that
in the show notes below here's some of
her work in case you don't know who she
is check our work really beautiful stuff
and today she's chosen to redesign the
Hilton Hotels & Resorts logo woo she's
gonna have her hands full I have no idea
what she's gonna do but the first
question I have to ask her is why did
you pick the Hilton logo what is wrong
with it are you crazy
help me out a deal why did you pick this
logo I can't hear you oh you can't hear
me can you hear me now
nothing nothing changed you mean they
still can't hear us
I'm not sure come on help us out what
about now I can't hear me yeah okay mark
do we have that is anything working you
guys I don't know is anything working
yes no I think so yes you can hear us
and then until Mark tells us the show
the show will continue on thank you very
much so
why did you chew on mine I could hear
you now okay you can hear me so why did
you choose to redesign the Hilton logo
I'm gonna explain it a bit yes it has
been a really rough week I don't know Oh
Maui lies or really ugly and redo it
right I really felt like Hilton it
needed rebrand from a very long time ago
yes but I'm gonna explain further okay
if I can't share my screen yeah okay
will you see it okay awesome so we're
doing a rebrand for Hilton okay but
before we do a rebrand we need to ask
ourselves three questions mm-hmm so why
change and should the change be
evolutionary or revolutionary mm-hmm
and what elements need to be preserved
to me to maintain brand equity mmm it's
the hardest thing anyone can do is is
doing a rebrand the creating a logo from
scratch is very much easier mm-hmm
because you can put your concepts your
your ideas and just go with it doing
every brand is very hard because you are
afraid of losing the the sentiments and
the attachment of the consumers to the
to the brand so I'm gonna explain more
what drove me into the decision that I
did okay so why Hilton local
inspirations the the famous page on
Instagram mm-hmm everyone knows in logos
for Asia
yes gonna say hi to Jonathan once posted
asking people which brands with you
would you rebrand or redesign their logo
mm-hmm and they have placed adidas
Hilton
beyond meets and version Marvel and some
other brands mm-hmm so almost almost 80%
of the comments were about Hilton
I love the comments I think some of the
comments that I'm added there mm-hmm
though everyone is saying it's the most
dated the most boring yeah I love this
the swoosh must die it looks like
something from the 90s and it's actually
was designed in the late 80s maybe and
oh I see
very long time ago so and and and the
best comment was because it's time yeah
Ricky asked me what's wrong with the
Hilton logo he's not a designer so he's
like why what's wrong with it in your
words in your professional opinion what
don't you like about the mark itself
consider it done Ricky you're fired
yeah because it's really outdated you
see this wish is really old the cuts on
the the the letter H is very old this
said the serif font is really out of
this world because you know all the
bread other other competitors are doing
clean and modern serif logos and it's a
trend now mm-hmm it has been in the last
couple of years all of the major brands
are rebranding in to a much simpler
cleaner modern logo so this one is very
old but it's really tricky tricky to
redo yeah
so the helton has been changing their
logos it hasn't been this one forever
but the changes were very minor so if
you can see the slides mm-hmm first logo
was the Hilton family and then they
updated the logos and this one in the
middle was done by land or it's a very
famous brand again the biggest yeah and
they did the Hilton Worldwide which is
the mother company and the Hilton Honors
which is the
awards program for the the customers for
Hilton mm-hmm and the the the Hilton
Hotels and Resorts logo so the number
one in the middle you can see that they
changed the Hilton Worldwide and the H
owners logo but they didn't shade the
head and they just change the font it's
still a serif one but it's it's it's a
bit modern but it's not that bad okay
and the colors were very dark blue and
an earthy color mm-hmm I want to take
the chance and say that I've been
working with Hilton here in Jordan
around maybe two years ago they were
opening a new branch in the Dead Sea and
I've managed to do every single design
for the hotel from the reception to the
management to the staff to the inn groom
to the restaurants the beach everything
every single piece of principle I've
done that for Hilton so I'm familiar
with the brand and that's another reason
why I'm doing Hilton and I'm related to
it and when I did the designs we were
using this one in the middle which which
had the dark colors and the earthy
colors and it was also during the the
design process when were well I was
working with them I was always asking
them to change the colors and change the
identity it was really really old so
there there was a rebranding but didn't
include the logo they did that maybe in
the last year they changed the colors
they are using a lighter blue color
which is the now called dark blue and
the light blue and magenta and a great
color and they changed the logos also
for Hilton and Hilton honors which is
way much better than the ones in the
middle right just simple ones and other
other competitors have changed their
logos so Sheraton they upgraded their
logos and they and using a sans serif
font you can see how clean it is
compared to the original one Marriott
as well holiday and which I don't like
but it's been much better than the
previous one occur I was and and many
others
so why Hilton isn't improving and I just
wanted to add something I'm adding a
footer at the end of each slide you know
you remember the decisions are owed
method that I do so to make it more
reasonable for everyone I've added a
footer every slide I adds I'm having a
foot footnote that that's the conclusion
of this slide it's telling me that the
logo needs to catch up with other
competitors who have already updated
their logos I see so you're showing the
evolution of these logos and there's a
question mark next to the what Hilton
should be doing yeah it's changing hmm
so he's positioning visual composition
of the old logo with main competitors
and you can see some are very clean some
are also needs of wiry brands and
rebrand is maybe it's not a good fit in
this case because we're doing a redesign
of the low career brand should include a
redesign of the identity as well yes I'm
not doing every brand of the identity
this time just minor fixes and it's so
let's call it a redesign and this is
this is a second question should the
change be evolutionary or evolutionary
when doing a rebrand you can't pick
either one of these two if it's a
Volusia nari it means that you're using
the same elements of the old logo
I'm just making them much more cleaner
and simpler with minor would less
elements as ADK cetera when Starbucks
they're just some of the famous brands
here
a revolutionary branding it means it's
it's a total change it doesn't look like
the old one
so FedEx and they even changed the name
from further expressive FedEx another
planet
by sharing my f and Bo daddy the new one
VP your Ventus converse so Helton should
go under the evolutionary rebranding and
why is that that's why that that's
because we need to maintain brand equity
and what's brand equity it's the value
of a brand's name from the consumer
consumers perception which is measured
when the consumer is ready to pay extra
for a certain brand over another so when
you have a regular cotton shirt it may
cost a $5 but when you add the Nike
swoosh it would cost like 50 or 70
that's the difference the simple
definition of brand equity and Hilton
has established a strong Brad equity
which enable to expand into other hotel
names so they have unworthy names 17
world brands with this here's a simple
infographic of their numbers it's one of
the biggest hotel brands in the world so
we don't want to mess with this image
that the hotel has and we want to have a
drastic change to the logo so consumers
won't feel detached from the brands
here's some here here are their their
sub brands and Hilton Hotels is the
flagship brand and the owners is their
awards so there so they have three logos
that the worldwide one the mother
company the Hotel and Resorts one of
their their full-service hotels and the
owners a word program so what I did when
I change this I changed as well these
two so that they are consistent okay
this is the Hilton Honors Program here's
here's an explanation about it okay
Hudson has created a new brand identity
and the new brand study they have
changed their positioning their brand
voice their personality it's now much
more vibrant it's it's younger now it's
energetic and they added a
frame this frame they are using using it
on social media and other printables and
they've chosen two new font families
this one and this one which adds
vibrancy to the to the identity compared
to the dark blue and the earthy colors
they were using before so we are keeping
this but we are also doing some minor
edits so here's some screenshots from
the Hilton websites as you can see
here's the use of the frame and the the
fonts it's called lo they're using heavy
bold and irregular and the simple choice
simple choice is this one this is for
emphasis and I've went online of and
picked their brand guidelines and I've
studied them well so I don't miss and
this is this is a real rebrand I don't
want just come come up and do what I do
and create an amazing identity a new
identity I just need the logo to fit the
current brand that already exists they
can just take the new logo and use it
just the way they are using everything
right now just with minor edits and
here's some of their principles it's
much much more vibrant as you can see
here is our story how they're using
typography here's some posts and some
principles they're using with the frames
and the typography I like to just kind
of jump in here really quickly and say
I'm always so impressed by you how
thorough you are in the level of your
thinking there are different levels of
designers and I just want to take a
moment to point out that some designers
would get into it and just purely attack
this on an aesthetic level I think
that's totally fine but you're you've
dug into the website to study the brand
architecture brand guidelines to make
sure that you're treating this as if
Hilton handed to you two million dollars
and said hey we need some help we want
to update this we want to be modern and
we want to hold on to the brand equity
you have I like how serious you are in
taking these things on always impress
have hats off to you so keep going
please
thank you I'm hoping we do
[Laughter]
two million yeah yeah I need to do that
but that was really hard it took me
around seven days of extensive research
and understanding the brand because I
could could have taken the easiest way
and just go for a crazy logo and amazing
identity that doesn't fit the brand and
they will have to reprint everything and
it will cost them so much money but
keeping everything the same and just
improving the logo which should have
been improved there a decade ago hey
it's gonna help the brand I hope they
can see this so this is this is from the
their brand guidelines
the brand persona at the personality and
the voice it's more friendly it's
exciting its energetic its vibrant so
this should be reflected on the logo and
the identity they are doing great with
their identity but the logo is lacking
this is their tagline I was going to
change it but I think I don't want to
mess around a lot with the brand so
we're keeping it
we are Hilton we are hospitality and
they're using their the this is the
exact same tagline they are using with
the fonts and by the way this is Hilton
that see this is a picture from the
actual site it's an amazing site hoping
with everything is done with the cob at
19 and the quarantine people can come to
Jordan and visit the Dead Sea it's
amazing here's another picture from
their brad guideline how to use the
simply joy simple choice and the law
font so I took the footer from every
slide which which are the conclusions of
everything that I've showed you and I've
added them to my decisions road map I've
done this before you've seen it before I
do this every time for every project I
do I don't show it to my clients I
rarely do I just use this to guide me so
talking about the the the logo execution
should be modern clean to fit with the
new identity
the logo has the same lock up of the
current logo we don't miss we don't want
to miss with would they lock up so the
other symbol should be on top and then
the name and then the others and resort
should be at the bottom the the logo
should use lines
so as the frames are the hero of the
identity that they are using it's used a
lot all the time it's the hero of every
ritual they are creating so we should
take this into consideration and it
should be used in the in the local and
the local should be symmetrical and
contained contains the letter edge
changing the font from Sara to San serif
and use their own type of typography and
the font families they are using which
is low this is the the main one they are
using I'm going to use it again on the
logo so we are tying the logo to their
existing identity by using the same one
so what I did I was exploring many ideas
I went crazy I'm gonna show you some of
the explorations I was doing just
staying within the decisions Road method
that I came up with but what I kept
coming back to is this logo there one of
the original locust that landed it this
had a very good concept but the
execution was lacking or it was really
bad I don't know what this was done in
209 2009 okay so it feels like it was
done in the 90s again I'm not sure why
they did that but I loved the concept
it's it's written on the website under
consideration brand new if you're
familiar with brand new they take all
the rebrands and they showcase them into
blog and then on articles so this is
from the press release from land or
they're saying the platinum platinum and
gold stylized edge this is that box
quality stature and richness of Hilton's
heritage the two halves are reflective
which are reminder of the company's
storied past and vibrant future and they
really love this concept
I couldn't come up with something better
and the open curves are welcoming
symbolizing the world of travel there
aren't edges blah blah blah what was the
wrong with this virgin it's it was a
cheap inversion of what could have been
a solid corporate identity and this is
the the the opinion of the website of
brand new they are very familiar with
three brands and with a they write
articles every day about three brands so
they know what they with they have a
strong opinion about this and I agree
with everything they said the the logo
is very old all old the the the two
words are not matching the font is
really thin I don't like the look up why
it feels like they just paste it there
and the 3d and emboss effect is is
really bad but the concept is strong so
I took the concept sorry I want to show
you the video and I came up with with a
cleaner version the same concept but
with a cleaner version I'm going to show
you the video of the logo process now ok
and let's dive into so I took the logo
the original logo of Hilton I added the
the the guidelines just to give me a
sense of where everything should go it
doesn't have to be to the tee but I just
have to stay consistent as we mentioned
to maintain brand equity when people
look at the new logo they feel like it's
the older logo but in a cleaner
execution so I took one of the the lines
of the edges the letter edge and I
started with that I needed to align it
with the grid perfectly this is a really
calculated logo it's really simple
design but it took so much time to come
up with the dimensions and the and the
measurements so well the video you are
seeing is I've trained on it maybe like
six or seven times to come to do it so
fast but the iterations took me
around two or three days to come up with
the exact measurements and execution
simple locals are really hard mm-hmm
that's why they should cost so much
money yeah absolutely so tell me why
it's important for you to get the
measurements in the ratio so it's
visually correct so when you do you only
add anything else when I'm adding the
the the the text and when I'm adding
everything it looks balanced it looks
symmetrical it's really important other
than the OCD parts and all designers
right so what I'm doing is a negative
space edge it's actually two two letter
etches two letter edge so doing a
negative space inside the bigger one
which is taken from the original logo
and what I did it's just play with the
angles I'm doing a 45 degree angle here
just to make the logo a bit more dynamic
than it is static you can feel like it's
opening it's coming towards your face
it's in a 3d effect but in a very clean
execution yeah I think the perspective
lines draw you in let's take a door that
opens and say welcome exactly and you're
gonna see that in the explanation next
it looks like many things it's really
simple but it looks like many things
it's it's welcoming it's like open doors
it's also the concept from the two edges
and the first reflectiveness of the past
and the future I'm going to show you the
explanation when the video is is over
I'm using the font they are using
already low and bold and medium I think
what type is that again it's called no
yeah okay hello it's a nice eye base
it's kind of exciting it's really clean
yeah and I've placed the registered mark
here I didn't put it down it's something
to do with visual manipulation so when
your eye looks at or gestured you see
that the local starts from this step not
from this this is the extension so these
are minor decisions that you take to add
to it to the mobile design and here's
the before and the after
so here's the final logo huh it's really
good it looks clean mm-hmm I love it but
it's really scary why is it scary
because it's really simple and I don't
like to do really clean and simple logos
you know yeah if you're familiar with my
work now I always have some something
added but I think it speaks for itself
and the second thing is it's a little
bit risky doing something really simple
because there might be something out
there that looks like it yes but as long
as it's coming out of a concept and I
did my research and they didn't find
something look exactly like it and
Hylton can go on trademark and register
it I think they're they want to be
having any problem and if they do it's
gonna be a really good success because
having really simple logos is really
hard to adjust they're just as saggy
heavy once said they were lucky to
register on trademark the marks they
have done before because there were not
that many number of marks and logos out
there so if they do a register this one
it's gonna be really good to anything
yeah hoping can we pause here for a
minute I just want to talk about the
logo the mark that you came up with do
you have the ability to zoom in sure
okay great so I'm looking at the logo
here and I think there's some really
great things and I want to talk about a
little bit about the scary factor about
working within restraints and it's hard
this is the sign of really talented
designers who have experience and are
mature because the tendency is for
designers to add things to demarks into
two packages and things when you should
actually be taking things away you
should be really thoughtful in what you
add to something just because you feel
like it and so these are the most
difficult marks to create for sure
because you have to balance unique
concept with simplicity and this is why
some of the biggest firms like land or
pentagram and say Collins that's the
challenge it's hard to it like work
within these constraints and come up
with something and they're the ones who
get pay the most money it's contrary to
what you guys think that if you add a
lot of flourishes and gradients and
decorative elements that you get paid
more because you worked harder on it
it's actually very hard to do these
kinds of marks the other thing I like
about your mark right now the symbol I
could see that working in many different
ways
translating into patterns and icons and
just it's so adaptable and so simple in
its presentation that I think it's gonna
last a really long time it doesn't feel
dated and I think what's interesting
about the corners in which you kind of
tweet to kind of create these
perspective lines is that it kind of
lives between a serif typeface and a
sans serif typeface it's kind of cool
this optical illusion that because of
those pointed corners it feels a little
like a serif but it's not so I think
you've done something really cool here
it's loving it loving it they love the
process and I think they like the
simplicity of it but I could really see
this on a Hilton hotel so kudos yeah
this is exactly what I was hoping to
hear because this this feeling is what I
got just today because the the the the
the as you said Chris what we do when we
add too many elements to a logo and we
feel like it looks amazing I just go to
the layers and start deleting one item
at a time until I think that it looks
good enough and it's funky
you know it doesn't need those other
elements till yesterday I had a star on
the logo I'm gonna show it to you now
okay
and I was convinced that this is the
right direction and when I removed it I
thought it looks really much better
so sometimes less is more I also want to
take a moment here to say something
about the the colors that you're wearing
and the way that your shirt is glowing
you look kind of like a design angel
today it's kind of like really you like
floating out there it's like wow you
just need some wings and you're good to
go
the white combination it's in sync with
the brand so thoughtful okay
woody what do you show us now it's the
local it's really exploration I did like
100 to show you the evolution until I
got to the simple mark
this is what it takes guys it really
does it looks like hey I can I can whip
out what hadeel did in one second and
you can once you see the finished result
but there's a process here and I could
totally see this happening in real life
where you would go in and you would
present rounds of exploration then you
would go in with a recommendation say
this is where we think you need to be
and this helps the client feel like yeah
I paid for this exploration and there it
is I just pick the top ones so many
explorations I usually don't do that but
it's really hard
rebrands going with the right balance as
we discussed everything and there's so
much work that goes behind simple logos
it's not just I can do this in five
minutes so let's go further you know I'm
not gonna stop here okay okay so here it
is on their famous blue color and here's
the concept again it's a vibrant future
reflected from the storied history so
here's the past their presentation of
the past and the representation
representation of the future this is the
concept taken from the original logo
from Lander building on an older version
and many brands do that they go back to
an older version and they they just make
it a little bit better and if it stays
in the minds of the consumer it's not
like I'm doing something really drastic
that they feel like it's what is that
it's not Hilton right so again that
evokes quality stature and richness
remember there's an a negative space
edge still there to itches reflective
rippln company past future there is a
hotel building you can see an arch of a
bridge most of off a bed an open door
you can see all of these in this logo
you can see anything that's related to
hospitality and this is the most
important one I really needed this
I have a question here for you a deal
this is coming from Sierra
she's asking I'm so interested to know
how does he deal find the time to do all
this research and work for local therapy
while also doing paid work how many
hours that she put into all of us it's
amazing so I'm wondering the same thing
[Laughter]
camping here in my office
between 10 to 16 hours a day I have my
projects I'm writing the book doing I'm
part of many organizations and the
founder of designers union you know yes
so trying to put as much effort as I can
now because now I can grow I want to be
the best branding designer in the world
so now now it's the time to do that I'm
not sure in a couple of years I can be
able to do that yeah that's why I'm
putting all this and I love it
I love designing logos I love designing
identities
I love branding hello design I love our
community so that's what keeps me going
[Music]
remind us about your book project again
yeah I'm designing a book it's called
designing I'm writing a book actually
it's called how to design a logo and
it's been helping me first in my design
process because it's written even the
most professional designers need a guide
that tells them now the next step is
this one and then this one and if you're
having any issues you can do this and
you can do that so it's step by step
guide to help designers and companies
and agencies do effective logos I'm not
gonna say beautiful logo reservations be
effective and functional and believe
it's gonna be huge
you shelf for the design community so
I'm very excited to launch it I'm gonna
need another three months I think okay
finalize everything and do the designs
for the book I'm doing everything by
myself which is time-consuming but
really fun well you will let us know
when the book is ready to launch so that
we can share it with our fans and
friends here yes absolutely
I'm gonna do a launching campaign I'm
gonna contact you on everything everyone
is beautiful can't wait okay some
feedback here that's coming in I just
want to read you some of the positive
comments here the owl is saying hadiya's
process is always amazing great to watch
decibels think wow this is extraordinary
design thinking very good because I also
get nervous when I do lives but I do too
every month but that's something and
then the introvert inside me hmm I
always get nervous but when I hear
positive feedback and and I see people
are learning even a little bit for me
and I get really excited mm-hmm
you're teaching a lot of people right
now I hope so I really hope so because
when I started I didn't have anyone that
taught me anything I was looking for any
inspiration and a mentor or even someone
to ask a question and I didn't get
anyone so I hope I can do that for
people it was speaking about learning I
think a lot of people are just wondering
you know how you look into this research
do you have any tips other than just
going to their websites or maybe even
the agencies and just understanding what
these brands are and their history yeah
first of all you're gonna know about the
brand you go to the source so you know
you need to know about their history dig
deeper so if I haven't dig deep in their
history I wouldn't have learned that
they used the old logo from Lander or
and the older versions and why they did
it you go to the website and
reads you go to Wikipedia which which is
not a really good source but it helps a
lot
you go to their social media and you
read what's the what are the people
talking about the brand how do they feel
about it and then you come up with and
you you see who are their competitors
and you study their competitors and you
go through everything again their
history their websites their social
media and so on and then you start your
design process your studying start
building the decision roadmaps and you
get all the key words and build a mind
map my mother mind map now is very
extensive it includes a list also of
other criterias that I restored the
research so I research jewelry I
research luxury brands I research every
other industry that is related with with
hospitality business because you can't
find inspiration in the hospitality
business because there is nothing as any
there is no certain icons or visuals
that represent hospitality in general so
it's it's hard just like banks as well
so you're gonna dig deeper in other
industries to be able to get the
inspiration I look into posters I look
into calligraphy I look into pattern
designs and everything just I just do
exploration for around maybe four
constant days and I write everything on
a piece of paper or a stack of paper
which I have here right here by by my
side
as long as I'm doing the project I have
a long stack of paper that concluded
from every everything that I do and I
write them on paper and then I Victor
eyes them on on illustrator
thanks for answering that yeah and sorry
for my English today because I'm just a
bit little bit nervous I think that I'm
not mastering my you're doing great okay
so what else were you going to show us
this is the clear space and the the grid
and the measurements derated okay this
took two days guys to do that's not the
actual drawing but to get to the exact
measurements so I really want clients to
appreciate the the hard work that
designers put into building their logos
having the tea centered under the the
the icon took a lot of work working on
training and the spacing which were the
letters I felt like off the tee exactly
under the symbol
I used to the golden ratio I'm not sure
I'm gonna I'm gonna stink I'm gonna stop
posting or showing that I used the
golden ratio in my projects but some
people asked me to place the gold rush
to show you how it's done it's really
simple but inertia is just used to
visually balance the the measurements of
each element in the logo and the
relationship between these elements so
the spacing and everything so here's the
earth responsive logo it's used when
it's in small places you do this all the
time and here's the before and after you
can see it's kind of marrying the the
width of the icon is almost the same and
the height the the under typography is
close except for the surf and the censor
and I took the same typography from the
the logo type I took it and I redesigned
the Hilton Worldwide and the heads and
honors keeping the same frame just
making sure it's the same thickness here
and
did some measurements that it looks much
more cleaner and it's more consistent
with the new logo and here's the local
Oh cups with and without hotel resort
resorts
this is used on hotels where it's really
narrowed with a stacked one so this is
the old logo and their current identity
they are using frames but the frames
that they are using now are really thick
that I think they are more thick than
this one and your are they're using the
the new fonts and the coloring is Ray is
a bit dark the overlay they are using so
what I'm suggesting with the new with it
was it what they new logo is keeping the
frames but making them much smaller and
they are near the edge so they don't
come over the pictures or over
overshadow any elements and the visuals
and just keep using the same colors and
the fonts they are using this is their
website as you can see the typography is
looking very good
I like really like how they're using
this we're changing the logo here and
the Hilton and here's on the apps in
comparison of other brands like mobile
impacts you're throwing 3d legible you
can see it you can read it even it's
like on the screen it's one centimeter
so you can read it and one trick that I
use to make sure that a local is legible
I place my thumb over the logo I make it
really small and I place my thumb over
the logo if it fits on my thumb on my
nail and it's still legible then it's
working that's a good rule of thumb this
is healthy New York appear familiar with
the hotel I just erased the the actual
logo the current one they put and placed
the new one so it looks clean when I
I taste the the other once that I
designed they just didn't fear right
this one just felt right it's on the
building he is they use from the
presented one here's the fonts they're
using the vibrant colors they are using
and here's an icon set of course the eye
cancer can be expand the criteria is to
use line icons that have got it just so
they reflect the global design and we're
going through some mock-ups Chris I'm
not gonna do a million one so we can
using a pattern it's a really simple and
delicate pattern the pattern took so
much work but because I needed to do
something that is really subtle that
doesn't overshadow anything it doesn't
look gimmicky just jumped it something
to add a bit of texture to everything
that's related to health and just keep
it simple and clean here's an ad and
here's another tip while you present for
presentation I like to go and take
pictures that belong to the same model
so you're gonna see the same model going
through the presentation so it's like
telling a story she's come to a
reception and she's now in her room I'm
gonna show you extra things just by
using the same photographer or the same
model the same lighting it's it's really
consistent so you feel it it's two there
with the brand mm-hmm that's a great tip
yeah and here's some mock-up in the room
you can see the pattern use very lightly
very very subtle way and the logo here
and here's an espresso cup with her
looking robe
and some shoes the the new identity of
Helton allows it to be more approachable
and fun so they can go even if they are
they are a luxury brand but they can
speak more to their consumers like
welcome home the slippers say step into
the comfort zone just make it really
friendly okay use Mattox
you can see the pattern used and the
backgrounds and the frames are still
there but they are really near the edges
they're not overshadowing anything and
here's the comparison of the new logo
with with the competitors of Hilton yes
I think it looks clean it looks modern
it sits well between its competitors and
here's the final slides showing the
evolution of everything every other logo
and there you go that's it very good
first of all okay I have some requests
because I could see everything really
sharp but the live stream I guess cuz
everybody's live stream and I know it's
kind of hard to see can you zoom in on
the pattern cuz I wasn't really able to
see that because the compression people
are asking about the pattern because I
know you're so good with patterns it's a
skill I do not possess sadly I was it's
not cooperating with you yeah we're
almost there then hold on computer hold
on yeah the internet file got corrupted
everything went back to thee but yes we
are we're doing the best that we can
yeah
so the pattern
the two better edge the one in the
middle and I just repeated them in lines
that's it
when I did an exploration the
explorations for the pattern I did all
the crazy things that I do usually but
it made the brand look cheaper yes and
maintaining again I
you should always resist the urge to
create something really over-the-top
when all you need is just a simple
pattern other hotels they don't even use
patterns but I thought it had some usage
it just some spaces it adds texture it's
just this one rotated 90 degrees and
repeated lines yeah I think I want to
take a look at is the ad or the website
with the frames or the border I have a
comment on that with the handwritten
typeface looking thing do you know which
one I'm talking about he said you want
to make the border thinner so I have
some yeah that without right I was going
to do a redesign that is much cleaner it
should be filled with images pictures
and just have white typography over it
sure no problem
this one actually you had one that was
side by side with the new logo and the
old logo and then you made the border
yes this one yes okay great
okay I have some thoughts on this and
this is just my input here in that I
think you were so respectful of the
brand guidelines and working within that
that I applaud you for that personally
just me I hate that script I face or
whatever hand typefaces and it's killing
the design it really is and it's just
hurting me inside a little designer
inside me cries to see such a beautiful
logo that you created that feels
timeless that feels upscale that
actually elevates the brand in my
opinion maybe more than it needs to be
for the positioning
I would have loved just to see a
different typeface choice that may have
some personality but not so over the top
because it's fighting it the whole time
the last little comment I'll make is is
the border I actually prefer the
original border I know it's not a big
deal it's just a minor little point but
when you have the border from the
original it's thick and it looks like it
frames the shot it looks like you could
be here step into this world whereas
when you make the border thinner and you
push it out to the edges it just feels
like a border it doesn't act as a window
and that's just my opinion but those are
only two little things I have to say
otherwise excellent job amazing they
would be so lucky to buy this from you
for two million dollars again Hilton if
you need some help you know who to reach
out to if you're the the chief marketing
officer chief brand officer from a
competing hotel and you're thinking damn
she is good I need some help you know
who to reach out to will include her
information in the description down
below I'm seeing a lot of comments in
here very positive super supportive
people are like my they're native
English speakers like my English is not
even that good you're doing great and I
just can't I can't even imagine how much
work you put into this and it's just it
boggles my mind every time you come on
the show and you do what you do and
you're such a busy person you're you're
a mom you're running different studios I
mean you're trying to help the community
of designers right yeah yes and if
people want to find out more about you
what's the best place to find out about
you a deal everywhere a deal yes yes now
are you going to be posting this live to
the Behance page yes prettier tradition
yes it's breaking the reason why I'm
here in the studio is because my
internet connection went out and there's
no way I'm going to screw this up so I
had to drive
hence the explanation of the mask I am
here with the studio with a few people
I'm just playing it safe
I'm also want to make sure my wife isn't
scared she's always concerned that I'm
gonna get the coronavirus okay that was
amazing
let me put this up again where are we
here I'm gonna put this up you guys let
us know what you think this is the
original logo the one on the left with
the circular leaf like puddle drop kind
of thing with the icon H and the hilton
with the serif typeface that's original
on the left and he deals more geometric
there's something beautiful about this
it's doors it's two H's it's reflective
with a simpler sans-serif typeface and
it still honors the original tradition
and the ideas of the original mark just
interpreted through a different lens
this is the power of good design this is
the power of design thinking that two
people can read a design brief and
interpret it very differently okay so
this is how you guys get in touch with
her I know people were panicking like oh
my god how do I absorb all this
information well tomorrow she's gonna
post this on Behance which she always
does then you can go slowly and in vivid
sharp detail look at the work that she
put into this and all the research that
she did the deal thank you very much for
doing this I know it was a big ask and I
just want to ask all of you guys that
are tuning in moving forward logotherapy
will not be the way it was structured
we're moving in this direction we're
only gonna have one person at a time so
they can go deeper and show us more of
the process so that we don't feel
panicked and rushed for time but we're
also going to be taking on things logos
that you love to hate that's it on
behalf of the entire team how do thank
you very much for doing this with
you